it's time for screen junkies movie
fights
[Music]
[Applause]
alright so what we have here we have
twelve movie fighters backstage ready to
go to war for you guys tonight they will
compete in one-on-one fights to earn a
spot in two three persons semifinals and
then out of 12 somehow we're gonna
Whittle it down to two movie fight
survivors and then you'll find one movie
fighter to rule them all
Roxy you want to get this started with
movie fight number one he's also on the
nerd go podcast
[Applause]
oh and also know this gentleman from
Comedy Central as well and this man
needs no one so we're not gonna give him
one oh yeah
literally just says Dan on this piece of
paper raining movie bytes champagne
decorated Schmoe down fighter etc
alright so the for this first question
it Susie like right out the game
this is a good one Roxy what's this
first question here we go controversial
what is the best alright let's hear your
answer first mine is as always
controversial Batman Begins that's my
favorite Dan
I mean I picked the Dark Knight oh you
have to Batman Begins vs The Dark Knight
gentlemen jump into the fun alright dad
come on throw on something you're smart
go oh you want me to go first well this
is my thing your thing is built on my
thing and if I remember correctly last
year I lost because I had a movie that
was built on your thing
I'm sorry oh no III got a list of
grievances we can go talk about no but
Dan you're one of my best friends and a
very good fighter so to say you're
thinking about how the Dark Knight is
really cool but it's very serious and
there's a courtroom drama about you know
Harvey Dent having to let all the bums
out of jail because he's turned into the
two-faced which isn't true that's not
how the legal system works they weren't
all just gonna flood and out of Arkham
onto the streets if he got found at his
two-face
so the whole plot is based on a dumb lie
what is he an Iraqi war veteran this is
this is terrible there's some real
mountain dew comments first of all I
don't think the Dark Knight is built
completely on Batman Begins as a matter
of fact I think Batman Begins is built
on the Batman mythos to its detriment I
think the Dark Knight you could watch
without having ever seen Batman Begins
and it works on its own 100% I also have
a big problem with your movie as a
Batman movie that's what it is this best
Batman movie I don't like the end I
don't like the line I'm not I'm not
gonna kill you but I don't have to save
you you're Batman that's what you do and
the Dark Knight did it much better when
he had the chance to kill the Joker and
it is such a Batman move to know as he
said we're destined to do this forever
but the thing that separates Batman from
everyone else is that one thing he won't
do and he doesn't in Batman Begins and I
have a problem with that as a Batman fan
you know what hey I I definitely a seed
that point but I will say there's more
Batman mythos and the little finger of
Batman Begins than your movie in the
first six minutes you meet Henri Ducard
and basically Rachel Ghul so you get
people who trained Batman he wakes up in
a prison because he got such a hard-on
for crime he goes to where the prisoners
are it beats their ass so like he in
just one moment you get to see how
Batman prepared for this and your movie
he shows up in a bank walking past a
bunch of cops I guess they just saw
Batman walk pass all the smoke of
cigarettes and drinking coffee that
sucks
that sucks no one no one sees the Batman
in her exit a paper rolls by he's the
Batman he crawled through the ducts with
John McClane whatever that's done I'm
just saying
when you look at the movie it is built
on a fallacy which is him having to give
up something or take blame for a crime
at the end of that movie because if you
if you look at the plot what he's trying
to do is take Harvey Dent's woman and
leave Harvey Dent with all the crime
fighting in the city
that's a stupid plan what's he gonna do
when Joker poisons the reservoir what's
he gonna do from his legal chair well I
don't think you did good I'll put a writ
that does it so he so Batman is playing
Bruce Wayne's playing in the movie is to
steal Harvey Dent's woman and leave him
with all the crime-fighting duties
because he's as good as Batman that
makes no sense absolute sense Bruce
Wayne isn't Batman because he wants to
be Bruce Wayne is Batman because he has
to be and the reason they fighting over
to Harvey Dent is because Harvey Dent
was the only person other than him in
Gotham City who he believed could
actually get the job done that's why it
says I believe in Harvey Dent Batman did
believe in Harvey Dent and he didn't
want to be the Batman that's what makes
him a great character he's the Batman
because he has to be the Batman and the
tragedy of that movie is that he loses
both the woman he loves and they won't
end the person in the city the only
person that could live up to his mantle
and that's why he takes the blame
because if you take that away from the
city they descend into chaos Batman is
the hero Gotham needs anybody I do
tragedy you put a bunch of cats in a
sack you throw it on a railroad track
tragedy is easy building a world is hard
building a world is hard you know what
else is hard movies right gentlemen
we're gonna go into some final thoughts
and start with Edie go ahead okay I'll
put a cherry on the sundae you know what
private Joker I feel like I was born to
lose but what I'm saying is that this
movie Batman Begins brought Batman back
from the ashes guys you don't have your
Dark Knight to love on so much the
continuous look that that movies gotten
for 10 years is so weird and nobody
talks about how it's built in the
skeleton of my movie my movie let out
all those rules my movie said that
Lucius Fox gave him all the dope toys my
movie states that he's a he's a
scion of the city an integral part of
the city Wayne is at the heart of the
city my movies the one that shows you
that Bruce Wayne is a real character
Batman is that the mask Bruce Wayne
wears Batman is the fantasy of a boy who
goes to Thailand to learn Muay Thai and
beat people up and goes to prison you
don't mean if it's a weird fantasy so
Batman Begins shows that Batman Begins
brought this thing from the ashes I'm
sorry the shocker - you're right world
building is hard but the fact is that
all that world building was already done
your ears is basically an adaptation of
the Batman mythos what did the Dark
Knight do they took that adaptation with
Batman Begins which I enjoy I think it's
a good Batman origin story and they took
that and went into completely new
direction with it they modernized Batman
they made a more relevant they made a
more current they gave him more to do
it's not just how did this guy get put
on a mask and become I'm Batman we know
about right Ra's al Ghul we know about
training and being a ninja that's all
already built into them Batman mythos
and Batman Begins leaves way too heavily
into it we hadn't seen it that's all I
gotta say we hadn't seen it
what the Dark Knight did was take the
building blocks of Batman Begins which
was a pretty good foundation and build a
skyscraper out of it to the point that
we have not yet seen that Batman Joker
dynamic tackled in over a decade again
in a movie and I don't know when we're
going to because that movie defined it
so well along with the definition of
Batman who he is and what he means to
Gotham City let's hear it for both these
movie fighter oh we have a round of
applause for our sign language
interpreter right
[Applause]
all right now it's time to vote
this is very difficult to great movies
and to great arguments so everybody has
a card with a white side and a red side
so you're going to show the white side
if you believe ed with Batman Begins one
the red side if it's Dan The Dark Knight
mmm what's gonna love to me this is very
hard
Roxy decide over here a little more red
over here but in the middle we got more
red I think you have to go with Dan
Morell on this one
dan Moreau we'll see you in the
semifinals every ro1 to lose but I love
you check out ed career Comedy Central
on the new Negroes thank you thank you
add gray
Roxy fight number two he is the managing
editor of fandom he's a writer for
fandom dot-com and knows a lot about a
lot of cool stuff Erin
[Applause]
okay this next question oh it takes me
back by the way we have some applause if
you were alive in the 1980s what is the
best movie of the 1980s your head what
the real answers were about to come
right now Eric what do you got this is a
great question in fact when I heard this
question I thought this is heavy and I
thought it has to be back to the
freaking future which is not only the
best 80s movie just one of the best
movies ever I recently talked about this
movie on sju you might have seen me
talking about it just how I think this
is such a perfectly constructed movie
everything about the story the fact that
it combines sci-fi and comedy and it's a
family story all these things roll
together that I think it does so well
and then also it's a-you know about this
kid from the 1980s and we see his life
in the eighties and how it sort of
connects to the 50s and his parents
there I think there's so much about this
movie that both represents what the
1980s were and what we see the McFly's
and what their family life and values
are how things had changed the time so
there's a great story there about that
transition and what the 80s were and
then it's wrapped in just one of the
greatest stories ever I think with some
of the most popular and relatable
characters that we've ever seen in
movies so that is why Back to the Future
is the best 1980s movie well it's a
great film it's a favorite of a lot of
people but it is not The Breakfast Club
[Applause]
now when you think about the eighties
and you think about the best movies you
think about what defines the era and
it's John Hughes and and The Breakfast
Club is his his best film and it is also
the quintessential brat pack movie it
gives us Judd Nelson it gives us Molly
Ringwald it gives us Emilio Estevez
Anthony Michael Hall and Ally Sheedy
acting their socks off The Breakfast
Club is not only a great movie and a
time capsule but it deals with themes
that exist beyond the era that is still
relevant today in that I have not lost
my thread I promise you it gave us the
term I've written this down neo maxi
zoom dweebies
spoken by Judd Nelson yep
and yeah it's about kids being put into
a box being forced into roles that
society demands of them and and trying
to break out and that still relevant
today is about celebrating differences
but also celebrating unity and that's
more relevant than ever now Breakfast
Club is a great movie and I love me some
Ringwald and John Hughes is great but
it's such a specific movie and it's like
Back to the Future has everything if you
want to see 80s kids in high school you
get that in Back to the Future you get
to see what an 80s kid in high school
would be like if you went to the 1950s
so you get to see that transition as
well there's our great quotes of course
in Breakfast Club but I feel like every
line and back to the future is a
memorable line and then yes the themes
about teenagers and trying to fit in I
think the back the future also does that
Ben in a very intriguing way by showing
you these kids you know a kid from the
80s kind of having to understand what
his parents went through and that's
the same situations he's having they
went through to the generation thing in
Breakfast Club is only confrontational
you know as far as this battle with the
principal we have an angry principal and
back feature too but we also have the
sympathetic parent characters who we get
to learn the whole different perspective
on so I just feel like back future has
all those elements it has the high
school thing it has like these themes
about you know the different groups but
it's telling this whole bigger story
where Breakfast Club is a much more
contained film Breakfast Club teaches us
more than life preservers are cool it
teaches us more than your mum fancying
you is gross that's about all we learn
from Back to the Future I love Back to
the Future it's one of my favorite
movies but it is not the best film of
the 80s
Breakfast Club is great however it is a
movie sort of only of its time like it
was a great 80s movie but of course at
the same time there's a lot of elements
that are problematic even Molly Ringwald
talks about that the main actress says
there's some problems with this movie
now whereas back feature is a great
movie of its time but it's a great movie
about time itself and so it just it
transposes all that so it you know it's
it's a great relic of the 80s you can
watch back feature and he's talking
about Pepsi free and things we don't
have anymore but it is also a movie that
you know so many people like I think
with people watch Breakfast Club they
can only sort of be like oh that's what
it was like in the eighties or back
feature you can watch it and completely
get an immersed into this time travel
story that shows you the juxtaposition
doesn't matter if you were born five
years ago or 15 years ago or 50 years
ago you can still completely connect to
this sort of amazing story being told
and that's our back future is the best
movie the 80s and just maybe maybe ever
what a flashback to simpler time the
Roxy let him know how to vote all right
guys if you're going for Eric we're
gonna see some red and if you want him
let's do some white right for Eric white
for Kim it's looking like we're going
back well fought him well fought
and on this panel we have a burnout a
dweeb all right all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
and she is our mother of dragons and our
own personal Sarah Connor leading us to
safety
Ross Hornets
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
beautiful mullets on the reflexes I rest
my case
not a single Dalton in the ground well
I'm obviously arguing for Patrick Swayze
thers only so far that having really
good hair and soso amount of talent can
get you in this town
Joe stop putting yourself down oh stop
hurry up Red Dawn ghost ghost Dirty
Dancing a brief and small role in Dirty
Dancing Havana nights important role
albeit an important role Roadhouse
Patrick Swayze was a genre jumpin mullet
having throat ripping son of a gun he is
the better actor whoa the more loving
heart and the bigger icon Patrick Swayze
Golden Globe winning Kurt Russell begs
to frickin differ buddy
first of all you just named movies I can
they move
- but I can also name characters and I
think that's what it's important here
MacCready Jack Burton freakin Snake
Plissken this is the man this is a man
who frankly I have to stop for a second
I'll tell you why this is a man who
genuinely from the bottom of my heart I
love you don't understand how I feel
about one Kurt Russell the granddaddy of
all daddies he to me the epitome of what
every action hero should be but he also
asked for a flower mention won a Golden
Globe for Silkwood because he's an actor
he was in the thing ladies and gentlemen
he reinvented for he is an everyman who
has full of charm and grace and this
hair is the only hair that could
possibly compete with one mr. Curt
appreciate that Roth let me ask you a
question when it came time to clean up
our YouTube community a little bit did
we did we quote a line from Jack Burton
to teach our audience how to behave in
our comments section no we turned to
Dalton until it's time to not be nice
and that time is now because you know
what old Patrick Swayze says at a time
like this
no but he's quoting Jack Burton he
doesn't and he does more with that one
Tai Chi's scene and Snake Plissken does
in two movies you're talking about a man
who went from being a Disney kid to an
icon of icons who continues to be he
isn't one Zapata in Hollywood tomorrow
and he's going toe-to-toe with the
biggest stars of today but you know what
we're fandom and I'm a fan a current
Russell I think you can tell I mean this
I am legitimately moved by Kurt Russell
every fiber of my being wants to be girl
Roth I crawl out of me so the iron more
into a lady Kurt Russell I get it take
over the universe I don't know want to
have sex with actors who hide behind
John Carpenter Patrick Swayze is not
just an actor he is a songwriter he is
this singer
he gave us one of the best SNL sketches
of all time with barley a final thought
here's my final thought I can't do this
on my own and as Kurt Russell has taught
us we need to do this together so you
know what I do Joestar I demand a trial
by combat and my final final thoughts
are gonna come from mr. Kurt Russell
himself
I would like Kurt Russell to come up
here I have a cosplayer that is
cosplaying for 1980s Kurt Russell right
but he could be cosplaying from 1970s
1990s or right now ego former the
greatest franchise that Marvel has ever
brought us that's a different movie
fight that we will do later Joe with you
and your hair
guardians of the galaxy Kurt Russell not
only an iconic actor he is an actor that
has traversed genre talk about genre
traversing westerns Disney kids sci-fi
he has done rom-com and he is a great
action hero why cuz he is full of joy
every ounce of his being is bringing you
joy and he's asking you he's asking you
bring him joy back today ladies and
gentlemen he's asking you I get one so
you're saying he didn't just hide by an
carpenter he was a product of the Disney
machine Kurt Russell is the man who was
given every silver spoon but not Swayze
Patrick Swayze crawled himself up Taichi
moved my tiny moon
slow-moving palm heel strike to repulse
monkey by a beautiful lake he saved that
town he uh I just I just want to go home
with a guy that smells like an expensive
booze and not just like really cheap
Pall Mall cigarettes and like natty
light I mean I get it's just a question
of taste and I respect your bad taste
Roth but to sum up Patrick Swayze in the
film Donnie Darko love and that's it
yeah love or vote for hair I know the
hair is very attractive you gotta keep
doing it oh we have semi-finalists here
and we are jumping into a Bligh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we are at afraid I'll pass out the
answers and then once everyone has
theirs uh Roxy would you please read the
question yes the question that they do
not know me - he's the best
the question is what is the best sequel
[Music]
let's go down from each person starting
with dance a classic in the musical
genre Blues Brothers 2000 baby still my
heart
we all love Keanu and here was a sequel
that didn't even need Keanu because it
was speed to cruise control yeah can I
do a trial by combat now this is a movie
that asks us the question what if there
were more dinosaurs it is Jurassic Park
3 ladies and gentlemen wonderful answers
let's just jump into it start fighting
it out I have a cast packed to the brim
with living legends I have the great
John Goodman John Goodman singing and
dancing doing something no one thought
was possible which was stepping in for
John Belushi filling that role with Dan
Aykroyd you have the Queen of Soul
Aretha Franklin you have Jonny Lang you
got the blues superstars of the early
21st century
all lined up in one movie what more do
you want
what more do we need as a civilization
are we not entertained America's
Sweetheart Sandra Bullock returns to her
defining role she's joined by America's
lost boy Jason Patric but against the
greatest villain ever Willem Dafoe but
not just one the foe
he's got leeches it's got a freakin boat
yeah that altogether you got speed you
got speed to when you got cruise control
it is unmatched in action movie history
everything's better on a boat ask the
lonely island I rest my case
talk about a cast from Mount Olympus
okay William H Macy 90s I can't a Leone
of bad boys if you'll recall and a
talking Raptor okay this is a movie that
dares to say what if a raptor talks and
then they do it okay this is a movie
that is old its audacity to reimagine I
take offense that is a that movie is a
one Alan Pony and I will not allow that
talking Raptor to be weaponized against
me oh we all know that Jurassic Park 3
is notable for only one thing and that
is a talking Raptor it's its only asset
it's a waste of talent for everyone
involved
dan Larson literally had to phone her
Rowling she couldn't she couldn't be
bothered to go to the jungle to shoot in
the jungle for free Laura Dern America's
treasure turned down a free jungle
vacation to avoid being in Jurassic Park
3 that's how bad it was
Danville you act as if the movie needs
more than a talking Raptor and I just
don't concede that point ladies and
gentlemen all I'd ever needed was to
talk about her and not only that mr.
Morelle
I I'm gonna challenge you on Blues
Brothers 2000 East only reason is
because you're talking about one of the
greatest comedies of all time in the
Blues Runner brothers being undercut and
undermined bastard betrayed it's a
betrayal isn't it you feel it you feel
it it actually causes me I think there
was a rip in the universe and you know
what happened I don't I don't care to do
anything to diminish the cinematic
legacy of the Queen of Soul Aretha
Franklin and I think we needed more
Aretha Franklin not less in the fabric
of film and John Goodman as well as a
matter of fact I think it I think it's a
terrible thing to look at anyone in that
movie and say I would prefer if there
were less of them it's not a
bastardization it's a celebration of the
Blues Brothers of music of life of
humanity oh we got a boat come on the
lonely eye things weren't cool on a boat
until the lonely island made them cool
that's why that song is so cool Keanu
really no Keanu no thank you is what I
say no thank you
I that boat can sail on I'll be on the
shore dancing to some wonderful rhythm
and blues music talking singing Raptor
dancing - the Blues Brothers look when I
see Jason Patric I rushed to the theatre
Blues Brothers 2000 has a little kid
blues brother disqualified on sight you
can't do it without Belushi they try
they failed miserably
if Jurassic Park 3 at its scant 90
minutes was just a raptor saying Alan
for 90 minutes maybe maybe but it's not
other stuffs happening it's terrible and
then there's just no ending though just
like here's credits because
a time and budget my movie has a town
destroyed by a boat and has a guy
yelling 12 knots 11 knots
he just keeps counting down and it's
thrilling as that boat gets closer to
the shore and then guess what
payoff hits and it takes out that
freaking town speed choose cruise
control deliver it all and don't forget
womb the foe and his leeches they're
coming for you I don't want to count
around any of those arguments because I
feel like they were pretty solid but I
just want to acknowledge the young lady
who said grease - and you're my people
that's it that's it I can't win this I
don't remember the movie I don't think I
saw it vote for three people
so for Dan we're going to see the white
side for Eric we're going to see the red
side don't worry about it
[Laughter]
just raise and that's going to be back
later yeah I think so they'll believe
you convinced me the pun award alright
so for Roth red for Dan white let's do
it
dan you almost floor and you know from
the nerd innocent podcast with Danny
Fernandez and he's one of the funniest
standup comedians writers and he insists
he could beat up several wild animals in
the end of a hand combat including a
kangaroo
yeah I can [ __ ] up a gorilla straight-up
strength of strength I beat this out of
a gorilla I promise you
kangaroos too I'll give him the hands I
don't give a damn like what do you do
you got a pouch I can [ __ ] you up I
promise you you know wolves can't trust
them they can beat me a wolf can beat me
but that's about it
I need to clear the air on that though
like I'll body slam a gorilla strength
of strength if had weights down to make
it weaker if me and the women for me and
the gorillas same strength I'll beat it
up put some put that piccolo outfit on a
gorilla where he's like just as strong
as me he ain't got the hands like me
I'll be to put gorillas all right Rock
all right just so you know I just want
to find an animal that can defeat
[Music]
someone said too easy what's the one you
about to pick yeah cuz I was like
ultimately ultimately I settled on
Mortal Kombat annihilation you know what
do you got and with me I went will
resonate evil y'all oh don't worry
alright follow me okay so here's the
thing if you want to talk about let me
take you back to the year 1995 okay all
see in the original Mortal Kombat you
think okay here's a video game movie
that like draws from the spirit of the
video game that we like and it presents
a story where we have characters that we
care about and there's like a power of
friendship kind of thing going on and
then we cut to 1997 Mortal Kombat
annihilation and let's be real all of us
most of us anyway played Mortal Kombat 2
a lot more than we played the original
Mortal Kombat so we're like yes we're
gonna get some dope characters for
Mortal Kombat 2 we're going to move on
the story this is where things start to
get real interesting but the Shadow
Realm and everything but they kind of
sort of skip ahead to Mortal Kombat 2
and also they've soap operated the
entire cast so where we had a story that
yes the original Mortal Kombat is
absolutely cheesy is it a great film no
but is it an incredibly enjoyable film
that's still a blast to go back and
watch absolutely Mortal Kombat
annihilation is unwatchable they just
went hey remember all these people you
knew and liked and you got attached to
these actors well we're just gonna
replace them mostly with new actors and
not address the fact that none of them
are being played by the same people and
we're gonna move ahead from all the
things you were excited to see and
basically just have a lineup of glossing
over throwing characters at you all
right I'm sorry I'm gonna start my fight
off with an analogy what would you
rather have would you rather go on a
date where since you swiped you like oh
this person is bad this is gonna be a
bad date you go on the date it's bad and
you're like oh I kind of knew it or
would you rather swipe on somebody you
like oh this might be nice and they stab
you in the calf way through the den
because that's what Resident Evil is I
knew annihilation was gonna be battles
like this movie trashes hell the first
movie was trashed but I'd like to see
Luke Han go so I'm gonna see it you know
but but Resident Evil tricked me I was
like oh this is gonna be killed we
finally gonna have our first good movie
I went on I logged off of my cowboy
bebop RP forums and I was like i'ma go
to my other forms would be like Resident
Evil's gonna be good then halfway
through they're like hey you know how we
kind of been following this story yeah
we gonna do some Wow is that as far as
Resident Evil kind of following the
story goes okay yes I agree I'm a huge
fan of the Resident Evil video game
series and as a fan of the video game
series I found the first film to be
disappointing that there was still a
glimmer of hope and that they didn't
really go off the storyline of the video
game series until we got to Resident
Evil 2 Resident Evil is not only not the
worst video game movie it's not the
worst Resident Evil movie well no but
that's why it gets you see because bad
is like yeah if I'm gonna eat a piece of
Dookie imma like oh that's gonna taste
bad I know it but if I eat a hotdog and
then there's and there's Dookie in the
hotdog I'm like I thought
it's gonna be a hot dog and that is
worse than eatin Dukey because I'm dumb
here are my final thoughts Mortal Kombat
should it because the original Mortal
Kombat was a fairly big success it
certainly has a lot of fans to this day
it's certainly a cult hit however Mortal
Kombat annihilation single-handedly
killed that franchise and in terms of
the whole cast being replaced may I
remind you how many Highlander sequels
Kristopher long bear came back to do he
even appeared in the television series
you know what it takes to get
Christopher alum dare to say no to
coming back
Mortal Kombat annihilation I know for a
fact I know for a pure fact that emma
has not seen Mortal Kombat recently
because she's saying it's good it was
bad reiten was white my man says Chinese
what are you doing okay but i'ma tell
you when you watch when you see Milla
Jovovich you like damn it's about to be
a tight movie and it was like psych no
we're gonna insert nemesis at the end
for some reason and then that's like
three Resident Evil's damn what is that
[Applause]
awesome haters
[Laughter]
well for me I love that you made our
sign language interpreter say stab you
in these two are massive horror fans so
we asked them what is the best horror
movie of the 21st French all right all
right Cameron who my movie features a
gay icon at the top of their game it's
directed by Jennifer Kent it shows that
kids suck and sometimes you don't like
your kid and sometimes you want you want
to kill them and sometimes you'll make
up a fairy tale creature in your mind
I'm talking about the babadook well I
wanted to go with the most terrifying
thing we've seen this century which is
the cats trailer but since that doesn't
count I decided to go with one of the
best zombie movies of not just the 21st
century but ever and that would be 28
days later
I think 28 days later is a fantastic
movie for the first 2/3 you say it's the
best zombie movie but zombie movies I
think the third act is where things
should pick up down to the dead that's
when they get into the mall that's where
things need to get crazy the third act
is not even zombies its Christopher
Eccleston doing I'm the captain now
routine no there's even feature zombies
the point of that movie is the monsters
aren't the worst thing it's other people
but the monsters are already other
people they're infected other people the
babadook is about grief and
understanding and it's a good it's a
thing that good horror should be it's
not just scary it has a point and
sometimes that's about what the grieving
process does to us that sometimes it's
hard and sometimes it's not easy to get
through things like loss and
understanding and sometimes guilt and
the thing about the babadook is even if
you remove the creature because some
people get really hung up on is the
creature real is it there it's a fairy
tale it's all a book and like any good
fairy tale it's scary as hell fair
enough you know those were all really
great points camera and you know the
whole grief thing we need horror movies
to deal with all the bad things that
happens in life so I get it but you know
at one point you actually get to hear
this weird creature with a top hat that
apparently that's scary and then he just
wants to nominate cats caring about the
movie Duke that's what he does that's it
that's all you're scared of a that is
not all what he does he also wears a
bitchin coat and he knows how to apply
makeup and he knows how to contour that
is not easier now the babadook do it
right okay 28 days later you guys we got
fast zombies basically the introduction
of fez zombies there's nothing scarier
than crazy humans that have a basically
like a Rage induce virus and humans and
zombies combined are the scariest thing
ever we also wouldn't have the walking
dead without 28 days later
that's maze the rip the introduction to
the 28 days later movie Walking Dead
basically ripped that off so anything
that comes after that Danny Boyle we
thank you for bringing back the zombie
genre and the horror genre George Romero
would be very proud he doesn't care
about the babadook I guarantee you he's
dead
alright y'all don't know bit about
contouring I tell you that right now
[Applause]
haters all right our next combatant is
the head writer of screen junkies and
honest trailers all-around swell guy
Spencer Gilbert all right make some
noise if you were alive in the 1990
[Applause]
what is the best movie of the decade of
the 90s and let's start with Spence
what do you got Starship Troopers next
question great great answer not just of
the 90s there is a movie that deals with
spirituality and religion technology and
futurism the feeling of the oppressive
nature of tech coming to take out all
this it is a movie that is prophetic and
timeless simultaneously it is a movie
that taught us how rich coats can be
while also inventing bullet-time it is a
movie that taught us we all know kung fu
and that is the matrix you a simpleton
the matrix is smart me an intellectual
Starship Troopers is genius this is a
movie that is so bad it's good and also
so good it's great it works on every
possible level it is a amazing movie
about like if the CW shows were made by
space Nazis and it's also a parody of
these kinds of movies this the sound
that just made was the sound the writers
made when writing the script at each
other and that's what happened and Paul
Fairhope and who made Robocop you think
there was a little more going on beneath
the surface in starship trooper I agree
Robocop's a great movie what happened a
Robocop is about Reaganism Starship
Troopers is about the middle east we
don't have time for this now I bet the
poet talked about the matrix I know
everyone's dressed like they're going to
a German sex club everyone's that's a
benefit you're welcome thank you
which house keys for showing us that
kink is awesome thanks for showing us
the new ships
I like Starship Troopers did you see
Jake Busey's penis okay I'm here doesn't
want to see that I'm going to go to bed
in four weeks you can all find me in the
orgy dome on Monday at noon
right let's talk about it now the thing
I've seen in the matrix we're nowhere
now the matrix not only gives us Keanu
who's come back from speed who's come
back from Bill and Ted who's already
been an icon twice over and renews his
icon hood as neo it gives us future
technology we're still using today and
it teaches us about philosophy in a way
that's digestible
oh yeah we're done till we all know how
good that turned out I would argue the
matrix is the first superhero movie it
gave us the way we have the world today
digestible everyone wins on the matrix
well yes Starship Troopers is in a movie
it's a series of scenes that make less
sense the more you watch them it's about
the horrors of it's about the horse
before take away all the like hacker
take away all the hacker trappings and
the a.m. screen names that they call
each other and the matrix is just about
cave and I got a special power and I
found the princess and with the power of
love Trinity brought me back to life
that could be any movie made in the last
50 years
even your Paul Verhoeven script analysis
and the matrix sounds way better than
Starship Troopers what you just
described is fantastic and also the
matrix is so much more than that
it gives us dows of Buddhism it gives us
concepts that are broader that we still
rediscover and it is a movie that's 20
years old think about that this movie is
20 years old if there's 23 years old and
it looks like it 20 years old and I
would still look so good and there it is
a movie with ethics and morals and heart
Starship Troopers has a runtime hi all
right great collision right there only
one ready to ask our foes let's go red
first fence Red Hills respect red for
Spencer white for koi
Dondre the chiana sons for another wine
white wine white wine right now you
couldn't buy like a bucket for a
comic-con you're like I'm still gonna
use my hat we're gonna do the Hat baby
by the way late night haul age if he
will be biting a mountain line that's
what happens when the studio's don't
show up obviously the answer is John
Travolta I have the great
Ian McShane I have an answer I've
actually said before and it's perfect
I'd like to get jiggy with Norman Osborn
Will Smith Will Smith is known for being
a charming charismatic great guy you
know what Norman Osborn did he freaking
took over the government because people
thought he was great and then he twisted
on their heads Will Smith's probably
terrifying and we get to see that side
of him we've only seen dark Will Smith
once and M night Shyamalan happened at
us we need an opportunity to see Will
Smith in his proper way see the range of
Will Smith and how dope with the theme
song be C coy well Smith is pretty cool
but how versatile is he because Maxie
you guys seen Deadwood all right Ian
McShane is a badass I hope I can say
that sorry Billy if you have to edit
that out I talked about an orgy demo
okay good uh additionally he can
basically act with any of our other
great actors such as Keanu and John wick
he is a great leading actor
and a great supporting actor as well and
he's the most evil out of the three
offices so just saying he'd be great
right which is good except for going
back to quois point the whole idea that
Norman Osborn needs to be somebody that
is kind of charming and you wouldn't
necessarily suspect so you combine the
best of both worlds in John Travolta in
somebody that is very diverse has had a
wide range of roles I mean from things
like Saturday Night Fever and grease to
you know his turn against Nicolas Cage
and face off John Travolta is a true
icon him you want somebody to go up
against Tom Holland who you're
immediately going to recognize as
somebody is an authority figure somebody
that could be a dad
to somebody that's you know his best
friend and John Travolta can really
embody all of those things again you
have a very versatile actor who you
don't necessarily suspect is gonna be a
bad guy right off the bat but he's got a
darkness no and I you can see it at him
I agree with all of her points except
for that she's saying John Travolta's
those things so yes she really is is
that we've had one man out of these
three that's carried decade's worth of
amazing movies that has actually been an
opening movie star that is coming back
with Gemini man that is coming back to
the freaking awesomeness that is Will
Smith and I would actually totally love
to see Tom Holland and Will Smith have a
banter off plus four decades Will Smith
has been wanting to show this darker
side and wanting to envelop and I would
definitely follow Will Smith for a six
movie right to show that darker side I
think the reason we've only seen Will
Smith and one darker kind of role is
because he doesn't do it particularly
while he's not very convincing I'm not
gonna buy Will Smith as being a bad guy
he's basically like I don't know like
everyone's fun uncle well what is he
gonna do again in spider-man dance yeah
exactly I mean listen this is not
spider-man Tori okay the last time we
saw John Travolta outside of a DVD about
a Walmart now and we've got a way better
western actor in wild well when you
really think Will Smith can play a
villain come back let's start with Emma
and we'll go down the line dureena and
then coy in a Norman Osborn you want
somebody that is going to be your most
sort of run-of-the-mill seems like he's
a good guy businessman is your dad is
your friend but secretly has a darkness
to him and I think that John Travolta of
all three of these actors is the one
that best embodies that kind of
versatility and also sense of presence
Ian McShane is the only scary actor out
of the three so you guys know who you
should pick if he's always scary it
doesn't work as Norman Osborn Norman
Osborn needs to be not apparent to Harry
and be paternal to Peter at first there
needs to be a betrayal there needs to be
a switch he needs to be a leader of men
that we feel betrayed by none of these
other actors will lead anything except
an unemployment line
Will Smith is the perfect man for this
job and he's been made for it from the
beginning and I think it's overdue
all right let's now only vote for the
one
so for coy let's go red Dorina white and
for Emma raise a hand man some of y'all
gotta re-watch get shorty Big Willie
style Norman Osborn that's I do look
forward to Will Smith's rap recap of
what happened in the entire film what he
lives with Osborn we have to find out
[Music]
sorry rule we'll get to the final in a
second
some big news actually just broke at
Comic Con and we're gonna break it here
for you guys right now and as a lot of
you know there was only one scoop stir
on YouTube that is bold enough smart
enough
sociopathic enough and loud enough to
break scoops of this level
ladies and gentlemen excuse McGee
[Applause]
oh come a car
scoops ahoy I will see you in court
what's up Joe good who's confused me I'm
sorry I've been away so long Joe I've
been working on my spin-off youtube
channel scoops universe it's going
terribly this is the exact right enough
time to let an inside joke linger before
we brought it back let's do it it's been
2 years baby no one remembers it but
we're doing it I'm back and I'm anxious
to serve up a bunch of new scoops mainly
because my cat is wearing my ankle
monitor and I worried the police will
discover my ruse soon am i right
so let's get started are you ready for
your first scoop are you ready for your
first scoop all right brand clan pants
fan plans this is fresh off the presses
former fans of new king of Westeros bran
stark were stymied earlier tonight when
their attempts to show their displeasure
at the new king were discovered and
stopped by his on-screen siblings sophie
Turner and Maisie Williams word has it
that some fans plan to Pelt actor Isaac
Hempstead right with dead Ravens with
chants including worgen - this not my
king and released the Snyder cuts
luckily eagle-eyed area and Sansa
spotted the troublemakers and pointed
them out to fellow cast member John
Bradley aka Samwell Tarly who whisked
the disgruntled fans out back and beat
them until they were unrecognizable I
heard they looked Samwell gnarly so bad
the rest of the panel proceeded smoothly
say four small pockets of fans who
started other chants including remake
season 8 Daenerys is my queen and
release the Snyder cuts what do you
think Joe I can't wait for this alright
are you ready for another one I'm more
than ready
pat pat falls flat my source is deep
inside robert pattinson 'he's yoga
studios talbin tell me that things have
gotten off to a rocky start for the new
Dark Knight ever the method actor
Pattinson took to the streets in a
homemade costume to fight crime to get
inside the headspace of the Caped
Crusader only to run into an equally in
character Joaquin Phoenix who's been
roaming the same streets for weeks in an
attempt to shed his role as the Batman's
arch nemesis the Joker and a fight that
one bystander called low on skill and
strangely erotic Phoenix's Clown Prince
of Crime easily bested easily beat
Pattinson 'he's Batman beating him Sam
well gnarly insiders now say Pattinson
confidence is shaken and he's now
scouring Los Angeles to pick a fight
with Jared Leto's Joker to get his
confidence back I've got one more if you
want it I can take it we want it all
right remake mate slate quake
don't blame the messenger this scoop
comes deep from a source inside
Disneyland's neighboring restaurant Earl
of Sandwich
if you're ever in Anaheim it's right
next door look it up
this source tells me that at the stroke
of midnight on the last summer solstice
a conference call was held deep inside a
bunker built in the smuggling
compartment of the Millennium Falcon
replica galaxy's edge on this phone call
where Disney chairman Bob Iger Foxx
honcho Rupert Murdoch former President
Jimmy Carter val kilmer and agents of
shields ming-na the subjects a secret
long awaited start to the remake of the
last Jedi that fans have been demanding
since director ruined Johnson's film hit
theaters almost two years ago ruin
Johnson more like Rian Johnson all right
[Laughter]
we're making the translate the main
obstacle to this secret plan is Disney's
already full film slate which now
includes a Rocket Raccoon spin-off film
a slate of hand-drawn animated versions
of Pixar movies and a live-action remake
of Pocahontas starring Scarlett
Johansson
I think she's good for the role I is she
playing the tree or the lead both fans
of the fans of the plant
fans of plants remake the movie have
already started to gather at Disney HQ
and Burbank starting chants like make
Luc great again Snoke is my Emperor and
released the Snyder cut that's all the
show I got Joe I got to go start my
litigation I'm confiscating the scoops
of high gear thanks everybody the duffer
brothers stole that from me at a party
ten years ago by scoops McGee ladies and
gentlemen bring Helen Roxy back up here
with a lotta love you guys
[Music]
alright y'all we have seen some major
movie fighting we've gotten some pretty
cool comic-con exclusives just now and
now it's time for the final one-on-one I
don't haven't seen Dan Merl in a while
we had scoops but Fergie
but let's bring back to the stage dan
Merle
boys on drove all right here we have Dan
and koi hi Rowan down for the title of
comic-con 2019 movie fights champion
what is the question
[Applause]
scoops told me he did not plan this
would I say Sophie's Choice I say yes
this is what ever
all right Internet I'm sorry in advance
and YouTube please just forgive me
the Snider cut represents an
overabundance of expectation it
represents a lot of people in the
position of not being in a studio set up
to do things that will irreparably ruin
filming we don't want to be in a
position where someone makes a movie and
then for the next five years people
loudly say hey let's do the movie better
if they already made the movie the
Schneider cut exists in a form but do
you really want to have a movie release
that doesn't have what you've imagined
for five years
the Schneider cut right now exists in
all of our minds beautifully and perfect
and I love Zack Snyder's vision I love
the universe acts Center was making I
love 300 and Man of Steel and the
imagery in the way he shoots I don't
want to see a movie that doesn't have
the technical perfection that Zack
Snyder would demand because that's not
Zack Snyder's movie the Snyder cut can't
exist in the way it should and therefore
shouldn't
I don't want to hear about it anymore
[Laughter]
this has gone on way longer than I think
any of us thought it would and at this
point why not let's just let's get
Schrodinger Snyder's cut out of the box
and let's just let's just get it out
there because you know what I was
annoyed by it at first but I'm pretty
damn curious at this point now a three
and a half hours four hours I I don't
want to I don't want to be talking about
this in 20 years I don't want people to
have to buy billboards for like the next
decade and like it every 10 years it's
like the anniversary of not releasing
the Snyder cut if it's so great let's
see it lets see it coy Zack Snyder is he
needs to move on in movies that he wants
to make I think Zack Snyder's earned the
right to go make films that he has a
heart for I think Zack Snyder should be
able to let it go and I don't think
releasing it is that because then all
the people that didn't get the movie
they expected will still complain IMDB
had to get rid of its forums because of
people we don't need to give them the
knowledge that they demand in a movie
and had it research zombies don't exist
for a reason this would be the
zombification the ugly decayed husk of
what the Snider cook could have been
it's dead bury it your final four my
final thought okay I will agree with you
Kozak Snider should have the license to
move on he will never be able to do that
if no one ever sees the Snider cut Zack
Snyder will be 90 years old in a
retirement home
staring at a lovely Vista and someone
will roll their chair next to his and
leaned up closely and say so how was
that flash Irish accent scene out of
woods a green screen done how are the
effects how long is it what do you have
a copy okay so yeah we need to see it we
need to see it in the mystery in the
discussion let people see it same
picturesque scenario Zack Snyder 80
sitting there guy rolls up hey so the
Snyder cut they released was that
actually your cut because I didn't feel
like that was the exact thing that you
know would you have really done that I
feel like some tampering I loved Zack
Snyder let him be alright Dan had
Khoi had no redford an white fur koi-koi
with the white boy you are comic-con
2019 will be fight staff
thank you for watching comic-con movie
byte hoot-hoot passing out the awards
longtime friend of the show Roger
[Applause]
barrage er
[Music]
you